- I have a plan.
- You've got a plan?
- I have part of a plan.
I actually had to get rescued
one time by the girl I was dating.
- [Seth Meyers] Oh no.
- Yeah.
My brother and I both were
going to be a stuntman team
and we would throw each other
down the stairs to practice.
I'd walk around and be like,
"Hi, I'm from Meineke, here you go.
"Four oil changes, $20.
"Pretty great, right?
"Cash, check or credit card today
"and we'll take that, no?
"Okay, (laughing) you too sir."
- He's an American actor and
one of my personal favorites.
He achieved leading man
status after staring in
The Lego Movie and
Guardians of the Galaxy.
In 2015, he was named by Time Magazine,
one of the top 100 Most
Influential People in the World.
- Alright, so I'm just going
to meditate for 20 minutes
and then we'll get this going.
(laughing)
- He's Chris Pratt and he is our take
on his Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number two is our personal favorite,
and we would love to know
what hit a home run for you.
And, make sure to stick
around 'til the end
to hear my special message to Chris Pratt.
(flying sound)
(intriguing music)
- I have a plan.
- You've got a plan?
- I have a part of a plan.
- What percentage of a plan?
- I don't know, 12 percent.
- 12 percent? (laughing)
- That's a fake laugh.
- It's real.
- Totally fake.
- That is the most real,
authentic, hysterical laugh
of my entire life because
that is not a plan.
- I am Groot.
- So what if it's better than 11 percent.
What the hell does that
have to do with anything?
- Thank you.
Groot's the only one
of you that has a clue.
- Ugh.
- You come to Hollywood and
you're chasing this dream
you want to be an actor, you know?
There's not a ton of milestones
that are crystal clear
that you know what they look like.
Because, for the most part,
the things that are going to
help you get to your goal,
are movies that haven't been written yet.
They're jobs that haven't existed yet.
You're kind of giving
yourself over to this thing,
saying like, please, I don't
want to be a waiter anymore,
I want to be an actor, you know?
- [Male] Yeah.
- And, so there's very few
things that are crystal clear.
Like, images of what you would want.
But, one of them is to work with an icon.
To work with somebody
like a Steven Spielberg,
and so that, to me, was one of my goals.
You wouldn't even want to say it out loud
'cause it'd be so ridiculous.
- [Male] Right, yeah.
- What do you want to do kid?
Well, I want to work
with Steven Spielberg.
And, they'd be like, "Uh, I don't know."
(laughing)
Some jobs you learn by going to college
and they give you an education
and then you'd bring that to your work.
And, some jobs you learn
by just being on the job.
And, from Cursed Part 3 on,
all the way up to Jurassic World,
my knowledge of how to be on a set,
how to act, and how to
handle myself on set
and approach work is continuing to grow.
I've learned a lot on every job.
It would be smart, when
on a job, to be a sponge.
Pick somebody and learn from them.
I'm getting to the point now
where I have more experience than a lot
of the people that are on the set
and I'm actually at the point where
I can teach other people,
so that's pretty cool too.
- So, another thing is,
well, you're riding horses.
- Yeah, I'm riding a ton of horses.
- Is this a skill you had
previous to this film?
- Oh, gosh, no.
I have been,
I'm bad, bad.
I guess that's how I would
describe my horse riding skill.
- Would the horses agree?
Do you think they could sense your--
- Most definitely.
- Okay.
- Yep, those horses, they can sense it.
And they see me, and I'm a big guy
and they're like, alright buddy,
don't get on me and not know how to ride.
You're too heavy to carry around
if you don't know how to ride.
And, I get on there and
I'm like, "Howdy cowboy."
And they're like, ah, (bleep)
(laughing)
But, I get, you know--
- So, in your whole career,
you've never had to ride
a horse for anything?
- Never for any kind of movies, no.
I was embarrassed on horses
a few times in my life,
growing up, so I had a
contentious relationship with--
- [Seth] Okay.
- The equain.
- And, was it just that you lacked
the fundamental understanding
of how horses were?
- I treated them like jet skis.
- Okay, gotcha.
(laughing)
- I was like, I know, I'm
just going to jump on you
and hit the gas and you go, right?
- [Seth] Gotcha.
- And, they're like, I'm a living being,
I'm going to crush you now.
- [Seth] Okay, gotcha.
- I just didn't, I
didn't fully put together
that it was a living animal,
a breathing being.
- Well, why would you?
- Why would you?
Who gives a (bleep)?
(laughing)
No, but I would just jump and say,
and also, my confidence would
quickly outgrow my skill.
Like, in almost everything in my life.
- Okay.
(laughing)
So, you only need to do something
for a second to think I got it.
- To think I got this.
- Right.
- Yeah.
Oh, so you hit with this and it walks?
Going to hit it real
hard and make it sprint.
- [Seth] Okay.
- And then, yeah, I actually had
to get rescued one time
by the girl I was dating.
- [Seth] Oh no.
- Yeah.
- The both of you were on horses?
- We were on horses,
we were on this beach,
it was supposed to
be romantic.
- So romantic, yeah.
- And then, the horse
just took off running
and my feet came out of the stirrups.
And, my feet were up in the air
and I was holding the
very end of the reins.
(laughing)
And, my head was bouncing off
of the back of horses ass.
I was seconds from death.
This thing is going about 40 miles an hour
down a rocky beach, I was like,
this is it, I'm going to die.
And, I hear, (whistle) yah, yah.
And, then the girl just,
just totally rides up and saves the day.
She had to grab my reins
and calm the horse.
"Yah, yah."
And, I was just like,
that was it after that.
And, that moment, we broke up in my head.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
(multiple speakers)
- In her head too.
She was like, yeah, I used to like you
but this is over,
- This probably ended it.
- Yeah.
- You are a stuntman at heart.
- Yeah, that's what I
wanted to be when I grew up,
when I was a kid, I
wanted to be a stuntman.
And, my brother and I, both,
were going to be a stuntman team
and we would throw each other
down the stairs to practice.
Never get injured, we would
just like fall out of trees
and hit each other with the car,
or fall off a bike, or
do like cool stunts.
And so, the fact that I
get to do some stunts,
I shouldn't say that I do all my stunts,
I have Joe Bucaro, who
is an excellent stuntman.
And, we have a great stunt crew
that works really hard on our show,
but when they write something physical
and like a physical comedy bit,
I'll usually try one
or two on my own to do,
and that's really fun.
What I think is so cool about
the Guardians of the Galaxy
is it opens up the universe.
So, instead of taking these new things
and bringing them right back
to the stories we already know,
I think it's like, open it up,
see what other corners of
the galaxy we can discover.
Bring in characters
that weren't, you know,
bring in characters that were from some
of the Guardians of the Galaxy.
Like, explore Yondu, explore the origins
more of these characters.
And, if it is Thanos, explore
the Infinity Gauntlet.
Like, how many of these
stones is he going to get?
And, who does that open up?
The universe expands, you know?
And, looking out on it, we
want to take these characters
and bring them into the Avengers
and we want to have them be
all in the same movie together.
It's like, no, that,
make a hundred movies,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- And, if they end up
crossing over, great.
I lived in Maui, yeah.
- And, but you didn't live in a fancy way?
- (Laughing) Yeah.
I lived in a van in Maui for
about a year, when I was 19.
- [Ellen] Yeah.
- Yeah, and so--
- That van, right there.
(laughing)
- Is that the van?
Wow.
- Would that be you and the van?
- That's me and that's
literally the script
that got me out of Maui.
That script is for Cursed Part 3,
the movie that I got paid $700 to do that.
- $700?
- I know!
I was like, score!
(laughing)
I lived in a van, I was like, yeah!
(applause)
To act?
Okay.
Woo, hoo!
That $700 lasted me one year.
- I bet if they didn't know
you you lived in a van,
you would've gotten more money.
But, it's like, anything will,
we can give him $400, he'll take it.
(laughing)
So, then you went back to shoot
this movie, Jurassic World.
How cool is that to go
back and shoot a giant,
big blockbuster when you
lived in a van there?
- It's so surreal in one of those weird,
full-circle things that happens in life.
Like, when I was there, I mean,
I was having the time of my life,
you know, at 19 years old,
just like, living in a
car with my friend and--
- So, oh, there was another
guy in there with you?
- Yeah, I had a roommate, yeah.
- Oh.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I had a roommate.
Yeah, it wasn't lonely,
it was pretty awesome.
There was two of us.
- Uh, yeah. (laughing)
- [Female In Audience] What attracted you
to the character of Star-Lord?
- You know, for me, what
I got really excited about
was that, this is an earthling.
This is a kid who was nine years old,
just like me, in 1988.
I was nine years old and so was he.
(laughing)
So, you got to think, this
is a kid who saw Star Wars.
This is a kid who saw Indiana Jones
and saw Back to the Future.
And Footloose.
And all the movies that
I loved when I was a kid.
So, if he gets, if it
were me and I was him
and something tragic happened
and then immediately after,
I was transported to space
and essentially given a spaceship
and an opportunity to become
whoever the hell I wanted to be
and it was based on this ideology
that's built on 80s pop icons.
I would be exactly who
Peter Quill is in space.
And, I would try to create Star-Lord
and I would want everyone
to call me Star-Lord.
And, no one would, and it would be
like little hints of all
these wonderful heroes
from the movies that I watched as a kid.
So, that got me really excited.
That got me excited that
I could kind of just play.
I could kind of be just really,
and approaching it from
an acting standpoint,
try to ground this thing in some reality.
I mean, we're out in space,
it's so fantastical and such a fantasy,
but,
you know,
how would it really be?
You have to sort of
approach these things as
in trying to thread your
own reality into it.
And so, that's was what got me so excited,
was like, this guy is me.
It's me, man.
That's what got me.
Thank God, 'cause if I have to act,
(audience laughing)
I'm going to blow it.
- Drop it.
- Uh, hey.
- (Speaks in foreign
language) Drop it now!
- Hey, cool man, no problem.
No problem at all.
- How do you know about this?
- I don't even know what that is,
I'm just a junker, man.
I was just checking stuff out.
- You don't look like a junker,
you're wearing Ravager garb.
- It's just an outfit, man.
Ninja turtle, you better stop poking me.
- What is your name?
- My name is Peter Quill, okay?
Dude, chill out.
- Move!
- Why?
- Ronan may have questions for you.
- Hey, you know what?
There's another name you might know me by.
Star-Lord.
- Who?
- Star-Lord, man, legendary outlaw?
Guys?
- Move!
- Ah, forget this.
When I was 18, or 17,
I graduated high school
and I moved out and became
a door-to-door salesman.
- [Male] Selling Kirby vacuum cleaners?
- No, selling much lower
priced items, coupons.
For businesses in the service industry.
For oil changes for $20.
Three year, four trips to a day spa
for $35.
- You're selling a packet.
- Yeah, it was just,
no, it was one coupon.
I'd walk around and be like,
"Hi, I'm from Meineke.
"Here you go, four oil changes $20.
"Pretty great, right?
"Cash, check or credit card today,
"and we'll take that, no?
"Okay, you too sir."
(laughing)
Please don't sick your dog on me.
I'm leaving.
- Couple doors.
- Couple doors slam in your face?
- Oh, God, yeah.
Well, I did the job for
about a year and a half.
- [Male] Jesus.
Got really good at it.
Was salesman of the year for the company.
- [Male] Shut the fuck up.
- And got a free trip to Jamaica.
- [Male] What?
- Yeah, I became a manager
within six weeks, I had a crew.
I was the perfect mixture of enthusiasm.
- [Male] And size?
- And nievete.
(laughing)
To answer an ad that says, do
you like rock and roll music?
Do you want to make money?
I was like, holy, yes I do.
(laughing)
So, what's this rock music?
Okay, your selling coupons, sweet.
No, no, they don't sell coupons,
we're in advertising.
Oh, okay.
So, anyways, I opened my
own business in Colorado,
when I was 19, and just lost my ass.
Point being, high
turnover rate in Seattle.
- Wait a minute, you
went from door-to-door,
year and a half.
- [Chris] Year and a half.
- Trip to Jamiaca.
- [Chris] Trip to Jamaica.
- How did we get to Colorado?
- The whole point is, if you do well,
one day you could have your own office.
And, that was--
- [Male] We'd like you to
run the office in Colorado?
- Yes.
Which I did.
But, failed miserably.
They put a lean on my minivan.
Pretty bad.
But, backing up, to answer how
I got into stand-up comedy,
there was a really high
turnover rate in Seattle,
with just like, one or
two new guys a week,
would end up quitting
by the end of the week.
A lot of the money that you make is just
from them like selling three
or four and then leaving,
'cause it's just the
job anybody's ever done.
It's great prep for being an actor,
in terms of--
- [Male] Lying?
- In terms of lying, walking into a room
feeling comfortable and having thick skin.
There's no better--
- Wow, thick skin, for sure.
To face all that rejection.
- Oh, yeah, people now, are like,
God, I just can't handle all
the rejection as an actor.
I'm like, you dude, (laughing)
they invite you there for an audition.
You're not like sneaking in some side door
to try to sell something
for, you know, anyways.
So, you can tell me I'm as fat as I want,
you could tell me anything you want
and it's not going to hurt my feelings.
I've got really thick skin
from being a door-to-door salesman.
- [Female] Can we just talk
about the workout regimen.
I am very curious to know what
you were doing, what you were eating?
- Really?
- Yes.
Was it just like turkey
patties or chicken or what?
- (Laughing) That's it.
I only ate turkey.
No.
- Done.
- Just eat turkey every day, with gravy.
No, it was really, it'd be, it's hard.
What I should do is actually
write the whole thing down
and give it to people because,
- [Female] Please.
- It took a long time, it took,
there wasn't any trick to
it or any secret to it,
it's just a matter of getting after it.
That's the problem, is people want
to know what the secret is.
The secret is, you can't do it in a month.
- Thank you, I like that though.
- It takes eight months.
Or a year, or a lifetime of consistency.
Working out every single
day and eating properly
and truly feeding yourself,
not starving yourself
but giving yourself
proper nutrition to heal.
And, you have to burn off all
the crap you put in your body.
And then you have to replace it
with really good food and fuel.
And, it takes a long time.
But, really eight months is not that long.
I mean, what were you doing in May, right?
That was eight months ago.
- Yeah, exactly.
That was yesterday, right?
- When you're looking back,
eight months goes by really quickly.
When you're looking forward,
it seems like it's crazy,
it's a long prospect.
Even eight hours can be a long time.
- [Female] Right.
- But, just takes a
little bit of consistency
and time is going to go by just as fast
whether you're doing it or not.
So, who do you want to
be eight months from now?
You want to be?
- Word to that.
- You want to be in good
shape, then get on it today.
And, this is uh,
us.
- Let's talk about this.
This whole, your physicality here, sir.
- Do we need to talk, I mean
is there anything to say?
(laughing)
- Flex, flex, come on
flex it.
- Which way is the bathroom?
- Was it over there?
- I mean, everybody's
been talking about that
for the last year.
- What have they been saying, Matthew?
- Oh, they've been saying
all kinds of good stuff sir.
- Oh, alright, like what?
Be specific.
- Here's the thing, do
you enjoy this attention.
Are you sick of it yet?
- No.
- (Laughing) No, he hates attention.
- I hate attention, it's so hard.
- You actually have something
in common with Channing.
- (Laughing) Oh, no, just one thing?
(laughing)
Oh yes, well recently--
- [Ellen] This is true.
- It is true.
It's true but it's sort
of, it's not really true.
It's true.
When I was a kid, a was in a small town,
I was a stripper for a little
while, for a little while.
(cheering and applause)
Oh, no, no, no,
it's not,
it was very low rent.
I was like the very,
very low rent Magic Mike.
- How much would you make?
- Oh, $40 a pop.
- [Ellen] Uh, huh.
- I did it three times, that's why--
- Nowadays everybody want to talk
'cause they got something to say
but nothing comes out
when they move their lips
just a bunch of gibberish and
act like they forgot about Dre.
So what do you say to somebody you hate?
What?
Anyone trying to bring trouble your way?
Want to resolve things in a bloodier way,
but just study your tape of NWA.
One day I was walking
by with a walkman on,
When I caught a guy
give me an awkward eye.
Strangled him off in the parking lot.
- Woo!
My head weighs upward of 85 pounds.
I was a 16 pound baby.
My mom carried me to full
term plus eight months.
I was born at 17 months
with a full head of hair,
a full head of teeth,
(laughing)
- Yeah, so show me your GQ pose.
What's it look like?
That's not what your cover looked like?
- No, it was like this.
(laughing)
- It really wasn't.
Oh, kind of
- Yeah, it was something
- Like this.
- It was a little not as looney as that.
- Yeah, I was doing this thing I called,
staring into middle space.
- Oh, is that how you guys get that look?
- Yeah, it's like right here.
- Right where?
- Right here.
You can't see it.
- Yeah, wow, that was really good.
- Yeah, no big deal.
- People's Sexiest Man Alive 2015.
Don't you think?
- Yes, oh my God, well he's my
Sexiest Men Alive, for sure.
- Oh, um, that's a--
- Don't be modest.
- Oh, don't be modest?
- I deserve it, daggamit.
- If anyone deserves it...
- It is I.
(laughing)
Meaning you.
- No, yes, it is you.
I think we're going to go--
- Are you saying I look like a man?
- No, I think it's, now it's time.
It's finally time that they
crown a women as sexiest man.
- [Female] Favorite animal?
- Oh, that's a tough one,
it changes day to day,
I would say,
tiger.
- Oh, okay.
Favorite vegetable?
- Mm, tiger.
(laughing)
- Well, you're not actually
inside the body of a raccoon.
- Not this time.
- Nor, are you inside a tree.
- Not necessarily.
- I have been inside of both.
- [Jimmy] You have?
(laughing and applause)
- So, yeah.
- What is your beauty regimen
when you are voice acting?
- Oh, it's the same as my regular regimen.
Which is a high sodium diet.
A lot of salt and soy sauce on everything.
Also, a lot of salt and soy
sauce on my face in the morning.
- Just like to just blow it up.
- I think it's important to have
my eyes be as close together as possible,
'cause deep down inside everyone
wants the cyclops vision.
So, if I can fatten the rest of my face.
- Your eyes.
- It brings the eyes closer together
for that thing that everyone's
just naturally drawn to.
So I fatten the face up with a lot
of beer and empty carbs after midnight.
As much as I can, the trainer was like,
if you're going to do
beer and empty carbs,
limit it to 12 beers and make
sure you do it after midnight.
- [Female] After midnight.
- You're outlaw name in
the film is Star-Lord.
Okay, so in real life,
if you had to pick a name
to represent you as an
outlaw in outer space,
what would you pick?
- The Boner Doctor.
- Hey now!
- First thing that came to
my mind, I don't know why.
- Do you help the boners or do you?
- Full service.
(laughing)
I'm a boner for hire, I also,
I can lend my medical
expertise to your boner,
should you
- Sounds good.
- Be able to pay the price.
- The doctor is in people.
- I did bachelorette
parties in my hometown.
- [Ellen] Uh, huh.
- Yeah, my friends
grandma had me.
- You'd show up like a cop
- Or something like that?
(audience laughing)
- No, I couldn't afford a
cop outfit on my budget.
No, I would just wear, I wasn't good.
I would just like slowly, awkwardly dance
and then go down to my shorts
and they would be like, no.
(laughing)
It wasn't ever crazy.
- Oh, you had to get paid
to go away or something?
- We said $40, here you go, there you go.
(laughing)
So, it's not like, there
were not sex scenes.
I got it.
- [Amy] Nice.
- Oh yeah.
I also got some dudes briefcase.
- I believed in you buddy.
But, you should put that back.
- How'd you get this?
- Fucking hilarious.
- That's not something that props can fix.
Sorry.
I'm out!
I don't give a fuck if it's dark or not.
(cheering)
I'm harder than me trying to park a Dodge
But I'm drunk as, right next
to a humongous truck in a two car garage.
Walking out with two broken
legs, trying to walk it off.
Fuck you too, bitch, call the cops.
I'm kill you and them
loud ass barking dogs.
(barking)
And when the dogs came out,
Me and Dre stood next
to a burned down house
With a can full of gas
and a hand full of matches
And still weren't found out.
Right here, so from here on
out it's the Chronic two.
Start today, tomorrow's anew.
And I'm still loco enough to choke you
to death with a Charleston chew.
(record scratching)
Slim shady, hotter than
a set of twin babies.
In a Mercedes Benz with the windows up,
til the temp goes up to the mid 80s.
I calling men ladies.
Sorry Doc, but I been crazy.
It's okay, go to him--
- Can you do any good impressions?
- Sort of, oh, there's this
show in London called Towie.
It's kind of like the Jersey
Shore of England, I think?
And so, I can do an impression
of some of those people.
- [Female] Will you?
- Yeah, it's like.
(in English accent) Like honestly,
I was like, Michael,
(audience laughing)
like, what happened, did
that Lance cheat on me
when he was in Ibiza,
because like seriously,
he's like, before he left, before he left,
he was like all like,
whenever I'm with you
or whatever, I'm like homesick.
I'm like, homesick, what am I your mother?
(audience laughing and clapping)
(bleep) off Chris Pratt.
Aw.
- Hey, here we go.
Okay, I'm really excited.
We're going to be sending a
special message to Chris Pratt.
Here it is, Chris, man, I love
following you on Snapchat.
You're really inspirational.
Just the fact that
you're so down to Earth.
You're snaps are weird and they're funny.
I love a lot of your movies
and TV shows that you've done,
I've watched, whether
it's Park and Recreation,
whether it's Guardians of the Galaxy.
I can't wait for Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 to come out.
And, I think the reason that I follow you
is because you're a super hard worker,
but at the same time, as
much fame as you have,
you're just as relatable as anyone else
and that's something that
I really find endearing
and I try to pass on in my classes
as an instructor here for dance.
Side note, if you ever
want to learn Salsa,
you're in Toronto, you're welcome
to drop by our school, try to dance Salsa.
I would love to give you a private lesson,
with you and your wife.
Hey Chris, it would make my year
if you could send me just a
quick, hey Aleks, on Snapchat.
Now, you just have to
make sure to say it right,
it's Aleks with a KS, not an X.
You pronounce it the same way,
but just make sure to remember, it's a KS.
But, the reason it would make my year
is because I think of you
really as a humble guy
and a guy who's hardworking
and when I'm teaching class,
no matter how good I get at whatever I do,
I always try to be relatable to people
and just getting that message
from you is going to motivate me
to continue to stay
connected to my followers,
the students, and the people
who follow me on Snapchat.
To make it an awesome experience for them,
like I've been watching
you and you've made for me.
So, I would love to do that.
You're going to see a Snap code
somewhere around me at some point.
I hope to hear a good shoutout from you.
Have an awesome day and
continue to believe.
- So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Annie Margaret
and Aleks asked me to.
So, if there is a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
please leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Chris say
that really inspired
you or made you think?
What was your favorite rule?
PLease leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
And, if anybody has any
kind of connection to Chris,
I know, I know, I know it
would really be special
and meaningful to Aleks if you could
forward it on to him so he can see it.
That's it for me today.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.